karine bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france un discours
annuel très attendu tant au niveau
national qu'international que peut-on en
retenir
bonjour effectivement on peut dire que
c'est un discours à la fois de force de
stabilité et d'avenir puisque il
s'inscrit dans une période qui est
compliquée comme le président poutine a
souligné à la fois sur le plan intérieur
avec la crise sanitaire et sur le plan
international avec une russophobie
globalisé qui se renforce et les
attaques qui se concentrent contre la
russie sens et à l'international
donc dans ce contexte la russie veut
rappeler à la fois l'importance de
l'état puisqu'il a rappelé souligné
l'importance des services publics du
fonctionnement des mécanismes de santé
de l'école de l'enseignement et de la
recherche mais également sur tout le
territoire acer que la russie ne
s'arrête pas qu'à moscou saint
pétersbourg donc l'importance aussi de
développer les projets dans les régions
avec un contrôle de l'utilisation des
fonds publics
c'est un message aussi qui s'appuie sur
les êtres humains qui dirigeait vers les
êtres humains puisque il n'est en place
des mécanismes de soutien renforcé et
aux citoyens et aux familles puisque la
russie s'appuie essentiellement sur la
famille et veut développer sa politique
de natalité
rappelons qu'une population forme c'est
aussi la puissance d'un pays un pays
dont la population ne peut pas être
compensée par une migration puisque les
individus ne sont pas interchangeables
il faut donc stimuler la natalité et
revenir à différents moyens notamment de
soutien aux familles et c'est également
une sorte de politique de grands travaux
qui se met en place avec le soutien aux
infrastructures dans les régions avec le
développement du tourisme puisque la
crise du coït c'est aussi l'occasion
pour les russes de redécouvrir en
quelque sorte leur pays pas simplement
de partir à l'étranger sur les plages de
sable chaud et la russie a une richesse
naturelle absolument phénoménale
et c'est l'occasion de re développer
aussi ce touriste qui peut aussi faire
partie l'économie sans oublier également
le soutien est l'importance de
développer de moderniser l'industrie
puisque la souveraineté d'un pays ne
peut pas être part cela il faut qu'il y
ait une souveraineté sanitaire une
souveraineté politique une souveraineté
économique qui passe aussi par
l'industriel c'est en quelque sorte un
projet d'avenir qui vient d'être
présentée par le président poutine alors
le président poutine qui a abordé
diverses questions on a l'impression que
le discours était voilà avec quand même
des grands thèmes la terre le thème
de la pandémie était très important
d'ailleurs il a les revenus sur la crise
sanitaire dès le début du discours
vladimir poutine qui vise l'immunité
collective d'ici l'automne s à paris
tenable selon vous la russie en effet
comme tous les autres pays a été touché
par la crise sanitaire du covin mais à
la différence de beaucoup d'autres pays
notamment de la france a mis en place
très rapidement une politique qui n'est
pas une politique liberticide mais qui
est une politique qui vident à soigner
les personnes malades et à laisser vivre
normalement les autres et effectivement
c'est une politique qui qui paye puisque
l'on a déjà dit fin le dea
les responsables politiques ont déjà dit
que effectivement l'immunité collective
en russie augmente largement est déjà
assez constitué donc le processus mis en
place paix d'autant plus que du coup
comme le reconnaissent les agences de
notation internationales
si l'économie russe a été touchée par la
gestion de la crise du bolide
elle a été beaucoup moins que beaucoup
d'autres pays et son économie est
beaucoup plus résistant ce qui est
extrêmement important en période de
sanction extérieur puisque du coup ça
lui donne une force pour résister aux
chocs extérieurs et ce qui est important
parce que ça permet une stabilité de la
population
l'égalité sociale à l'intérieur du pays
le changement climatique était également
au coeur de ce discours le président
russe a promis de lutter contre le
réchauffement de la planète alors même
que le la russie est un des producteurs
majeurs d'hydrocarbures et subit des
catastrophes écologiques est ce que
c'est un défi de taille
pour la russie le patrimoine naturel et
pays effectivement très important il
faut non seulement le préserver mais il
faut le développer
mais le développer réellement est ce qui
est intéressant dans le discours en
russie à la différence de beaucoup
d'autres pays c'est que nous ne sommes
pas dans une sorte de culte écologique
idéologique mais dans un cadre assez
concret c'est que il y a eu des des
crises écologique 1 parce que certain
nombre de mesures de sécurité n'ont pas
été mises en place pour protéger
justement des déversements de produits
techniques toxiques par branche il est
donc effectivement important à la fois
de trouver un juste milieu entre le
développement de l'industrie puisque
l'industrie nécessaires pour le
développement d'un pays et la protection
de la nature et c'est cet équilibre qui
est important effectivement de trouver
pour un développement stable et profond
du pays alors un discours qui se tient
dans un contexte international assez
tendue vadimir poutine qui a d'ailleurs
rappelé ses rivaux étrangers à ne pas
franchir deux lignes rouges avec la
russie il veut toutefois garder une
bonne relation avec la communauté
internationale
c'est un message fort adressé aux
occidentaux
oui la russie répète effectivement ceux
qui n'ont pas compris que le fait d'être
diplomate ne veut pas dire être faible
celle que la russie ne cherche pas la
confrontation mais ne va pas accepter
une agression donc elle propose aux
leaders internationaux de revenir un
petit peu en arrière de faire baisser la
pression d'arrêter l'hystérie et de
reprendre un discours constructif
d'autant plus que comme l'a rappelé le
président poutine à la fois sur le plan
militaire la russie a largement
moderniser son armée donc en cas
d'agression aller apte à répondre ce
qu'ils ont aussi fait réfléchir et
d'autre part que beaucoup de conflits
internationaux comme la syrie comme dans
le sud de
d amérique du sud ne sont pas réglés
sans la russie
donc c'est un partenaire important sur
la scène internationale
que ce soit en libye que ce soit en
syrie se sont en afrique et c'est un
partenaire dont la communauté nationale
a besoin si évidemment le guide qui
n'était international dépendent en
tranches de mettre en place un chaos
généralisé dans la logique du puisque je
ne peux pas gouverner j'ai détruit
espérons quand même qu'ils dressent
encore une phrase également dans ce
discours certains se sont habitués à la
pratique des sanctions illégales contre
à l'économie une allusion bien
évidemment aux sanctions américaines
comment est-ce que la russie pourrait
répondre à la russie répondent petit à
petit au fur et à mesure ce qui est
important c'est de ne pas prendre des
mesures qui pourraient porter préjudice
au développement intérieur du pays
puisque le but de ces sanctions c'est de
déstabiliser le pays en déstabilisant
l'économique donc provoquer des
problèmes sociaux au monde il est
important que la russie ne provoque pas
de ses propres mains des problèmes
sociaux que les états unis dillon le
monde atlantis ne n'arrive pas à
provoquer avec ces sanctions si qui est
très important est la meilleure réponse
évidemment et comme l'a fait la rue 6
est maintenant de réagir très rapidement
de réagir politiquement elle l'a fait
montrer ça va faire réfléchir et ça fait
déjà réfléchir
lavrov a déjà dit que il y avait aussi
la possibilité de taper sur l'économie
américaine si jamais vraiment veille
d'un avion vide elle jusque là il garde
son camp dans la manche et ils peuvent
tout à fait l'utiliser la meilleure
réponse de la russie c'est de se
renforcer de développer son pays de
développer son économie réelle de
développer son industrie d'avoir une
école un enseignement fort puisque ses
skis base en fait c'est ce qui donne les
fondements pour la population pour
qu'elle puisse avoir les connaissances
qui nous permettent d'avoir une force
intérieure suffisante pour ne pas être
manipulé puisque l'on voit que beaucoup
de révolutions fonctionne parce que la
population de ces pays et manipulent
donc quand le président parle aussi de
l'importance de revenir sur les manières
d'histoire qui en russie qui parfois ont
une présentation assez
surprenante on va dire de l'histoire du
pays ça aussi c'est une réponse qui est
très important c'est à dire reprendre en
main son histoire ne pas la laisser
manipuler de l'extérieur permettre à son
pays de se développer à sa population
d'être forte et fière d'être russe et
c'est ça mon avis de la meilleure
réponse pour ne pas redonner les
conditions des années 90 où il y avait
une espèce on va dire deux de trop
grande confiance me lapp dans la
population russe qui croyait au miracle
occidentale maintenant heureusement les
masques malheureusement tout cas pour
l'occident les masques sont tombés et à
la russie comprend très bien que s'il ya
effectivement une très belle
civilisation européenne passait
actuellement malheureusement l'occident
à peu de choses bénéfiques à apporter
merci beaucoup karine d'échec de l'offre
comme professeur invité à l'université
d'état de moscou d'avoir décrypter avec
nous à ce discours du président au russe
vladimir poutine vont qui s'est adressé
ce matin à la nation un discours annuel
merci beaucoup karine des chevaux locaux